Film Courage: How many filmmakers
do who make a living making movies?
Glen Reynolds, Founder of Circus Road Films: I've
had several clients who have gone on to great
careers in making films. I sold Shaka King's
first film Newlyweeds who went on to Judas
in the Messiah one of Mike Flanagan's early films
Absentia now made this the the The Shining sequel
and lots of other great horror films and series
for Netflix. I co-produced and helped sell several
films with Ron Bergman who's a producer, he's
now partnered with Rian Johnson and they did
Star Wars 8 and Looper and several other
and Knives Out and several other great films
so I have a handful of clients that have
gone on to to have great Hollywood careers.
I have a few clients as well that still
make movies they're still trying to make
that one that graduates to the studio
level but still making indie films
some still very indie some kind of in the
quasi-hollywood indie world of catching
talent and having sales agents pre-sell
their movies there's lots of those movies
that kind of out there that don't bubble up
but still kind of make money in strange ways
and and then there's a lot of people that are one
and done just because it was so such a big effort
to get that first one out there and they just
never could get quite back to making number two
that's partly because it's just hard
to make a film that makes money and
and I think it's it's easier when you're
young I like to bootstrap it and do it for
nothing and get all call in all your favors
but it's hard to call in the favors twice
so yeah it's definitely a mix sure
and if you have debt from the movie
yeah that's difficult yeah yeah so and most
people I know were I think most films I rep
were mostly equity most of them tend to be
have found an equity investor to make the
film as opposed to renting their credit cards
so it's not debt per se and that they have to
pay it back they just have disgruntled investors
maybe but or not overly happy but but yeah I think
it's yeah it's just it's just not it's not easy to
make a movie and it's I'd say me I don't know what
the percentages are but I'd say probably 70 80
percent don't go on to make a second film at least
well that's that's high that's unfortunate but
yeah well there's just a lot of stuff
that we've got a lot of movies out there
and it's not that like they don't go on to
do great things other ways right like it's
same I've definitely had clients like like well
I made this film but I'm never doing it again
like they that's the way they feel after after
making for one like it's just it was a lot to
to get that one off the ground whatever that
felt like to them so yeah it's not always a
sad story it's sometimes just what they choose
they just choose a new path right they got it
out of their system yeah yeah exactly what's the
budget range of the movies you typically work with
yeah the range is micro to like almost
nothing to several million three four million
I'm maybe a couple times I've had seven million
dollar films but pretty rare how does a half
million dollar movie make its money back so there
are lots of potential ways to make it back but
for a half million dollar movie you most
likely need to get it into a major festival
and have someone pay you
that and more back up front
because if you most half million dollar films
don't make their money back so that's you know
it's just half a million dollars it implies
no cast really right that when I say no castle
there are people in the movie but there's no
names in the movie per se that help sell it
and that's you're going up against a lot of
independent films out there that have names
that were made at two million dollars and even
those movies don't get sometimes don't get a
half million dollars for their U.S sale so you're
really up against it it's really it's tough but I
have had plenty of half million dollar movies that
made a hundred thousand in the transactional VOD
world the distributor managed to sell to cable
entity for a couple hundred thousand and then
it made more money on AVOD to get to that half
million dollar number and I'm sorry AVOD sorry
advertising video on demand and that's where the
ads play that's where the ads is okay great sorry
are there certain films that are domestically made
but they are hits overseas but they're not here
it's pretty rare these days the one of the
reasons I decided to get into domestic sales
as a producer rep as opposed to International
sales was I saw it going down 15 years ago
there was a day when International sales was Major
and talk about we're talking about true Indies
here okay not there's still a market overseas for
films with names in quasi-independent films made
by Hollywood production companies we talk about
true indie films there's barely a market now
overseas and that's partly because at one point
we we used to be able to sell almost anything
overseas 25 years ago the this is there were cable
channels around the world and video stores around
the world that needed content and U.S producers
were the only ones that could make them at a price
and we were the only ones really doing it in mass
and so we were flooding the world with our content
so fast forward past the writer strike creates the
reality television and the cost of production all
comes down and countries around the world start
making their own content for their own communities
there's just not there's just no demand
anymore at all for true independent films
there's still a pretty good I almost say good
but there's still a business for films in the
three million dollars and up range that are made
in not with that with the studio but independently
in Hollywood with a name attached to it where they
can make sales around the world that come up to 50
to 70 percent of a budget but that doesn't exist
for true independence even if they get someone
and they pay them a day rate maybe they weren't
they're not an a-lister but they're recognizable
yeah these days you it's like you to me for for
sales purposes it's really A-list or nothing
I think when you're when you're if
you're gonna if you're casting for
name value and it's that level you should
also be making you should probably really
be getting them because they're really great for
the role much more important than what their name
value is and you're hoping that the combination
of them being great for the role and a little
bit of name value catapults it into another
sphere then the you everything else out there
but yeah I see a lot of films that cast B level
talent I should say not level but value talent
for that purpose and it just
doesn't didn't make a difference
right I'm just thinking of overseas as well
so it sounds like maybe 15 16 20 years ago
yeah we could do that easily back then there
was a it was a day when you could just tell
an international distributor oh I've got so
and so in it and and they just believed you
right and that they didn't even know that the
person had value or not and that's how that's how
Westworld it was at one point or Wild but
they're all much more sophisticated now
they'll know exactly what they need and what their
audiences want and who's worth what and so it's
it's really kind of again there's again going
back to those three million dollar level films
where there are some actors that have kind of
popped up in value because they were in big studio
films and so there's a certain recognizability
there's certain name value that's still there but
they're not getting they're not leading roles
in in big studio movies they still are trying
out for them maybe they're trying to be the next
Marvel guy or whatever but they're not getting it
but they still have some value so for a few years
they'll be castable in that kind of budget range
and usually in thrillers or horror films or
elevated horror something very commercial
action as well but but it's but that list is
pretty it's a pretty small list and it changes
and it's subjective too I find that like just
because one sales company has an affinity
for one level one actor with a little
bit of name value they might have
that Affinity because they had a film last
year that they sold with him that did well
but the sales agent over here doesn't have that
experience and doesn't didn't hasn't made a film
with that guy so they don't have this put the
same value on him that that other company does
so it's not like a a where like you can't rely
on IMDb scores for Value they really sometimes
they correlate but most of the time they don't
because people pop up and down on that list
pretty wildly now with faith-based films is the
only place to sell them is to certain Networks
yeah I'm not that conversant and faith-based
stuff I've never sold a faith-based film
from what I understand there's a mega church
that kind of there's one or two of them that
have done quite a good job in the past of of
of creating these faith-based films for their
their audiences and and Screen those
films for the churches as a way to
create a Groundswell for selling
off the ancillary rights later
and and and I think that there's their faith-based
production companies that have kind of figured
out the formula and the name value that they
need and can kind of and know how to do that
but if someone came to me with a face faith-based
film I'd say hey if it if it also works for
a secular audience I know where to go with it
but if it's purely faith-based and very or very
overtly faith-based there's better there's there's
routes that I don't really know that much about.